Ouiiii bonjour ! C'est parti pour l'aventure ! On y va !
Eh bien bonjour mes amis!
Nous sommes au Japon, actuellement, à Kyoto
avec un bigorneau...(futur nom de Squeezie)
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait au Japon, les amis ?
C'est assez fou, on est venu ici pour sept jours
Et, en fait, on va aller simplement voir un potentiel chien ...
... que je vais adopter en fin d'année.
Faudra que je revienne au Japon le chercher dans un mois si c'est le bon
Squeezie: ... on le voit demain
Maxenss: Parce qu'on a décidé d'adopter tous les deux
Mon bébé depuis le temps que t'attends ce bébé
On a décidé de ça et euh..
ça sera un beau chien
alors pourquoi je vais jusqu'au Japon pour adopter un chien la question est très légitime parce que je vais adopter un
Shiba Inu ! Un Shiba Inu c'est une race de chien
japonaise et y'a beaucoup d'élevages en france mais j'ai pas hyper confiance bref j'ai vécu des expériences qui font que j'ai pas confiance à 100%
et je me disais quitte à avoir un chien japonais pourquoi ne pas l'adopter dans son pays d'origine
à savoir directement au Japon je suis passé par un organisme qui a cherché dans des élevages au japon pour moi un truc hyper sérieux
hyper clean ils ont trouvé un élevage j'ai reçu plein de vidéos là ces quatre dernières semaines je bavais littéralement devant
Vous avez maintenant autant hâte que nous en attendant aujourd'hui je vais te faire visiter un peu Kyoto on va aller sur les traces
de ce que j'ai fait avec mon frère et mon père on va boire du saké
non pasteurisé anecdote quand on avait bu un verre chacun de saké et ensuite on est allés dans un magasin côté on a chacun achetés une montre
donc tu vas peut-être acheter une montre
Ahh ! Why not c'est que j'en avait bien besoin
Allez c'est parti pour visiter Kyoto
[MUSIQUE : Electric Guest - Oh Devil]
Bon je voulais qu'on aille boire le saké et non pasteurisé au marché mais j'ai oublié que ici au Japon il est 9h30 du matin
déjà quand t'en bois à 13 heures tu finis tu achètes une montre t'en bois à 9h00 mec t'achètes une maison ici il faut faire attention
du coup on s'est rabattu sur un magasin extrêmement cool qui s'appelle Masterpiece c'est dans ce magasin là que j'ai acheté ce sac extrêmement cool et
Maxence a besoin d'un sac donc ça tombe plutôt bien corrélation ! Je cherche un sac parce qu'il faut savoir que j'ai ce sac depuis le collège
mais c'est totalement ridicule maintenant d'avoir un sac Etnies, déjà à l'époque on se foutait de ma gueule, on me disait ''Eh ! Tu fais du parachute ?''
ENORME!!!Et du coup en fait c'est le seul sac dans lequel je rentrer mon ordi
du coup je me trimbale tout le temps avec du coup est-ce-qu'on peut dire que la problématique de ce vlog est ouf ?
c'est-à-dire il faut trouver un sac à Maxenss c'est ça on est venu au Japon juste pour ça on est venu dizaine de jours
[MUSIQUE : TLC - It's Sunny]
Thank you so much ! Bye !
On vient de sortir de la boutique. Maxenss tu peux montrer ton nouveau sac s'il te plait
Il en a même pas acheté !Mais Maxenss c'est pas grave
Ça va
Je te donne celui-là regarde il est super celui-là
Il contient ce que moi j'ai pu acheter
-Est-ce que tu es d'accord pour dire que c'est l'une des boutiques le plus stylées que tu aies fait de ta vie
c'est vraiment trop bien l'ambiance est super
les vendeurs sont trop cool on a pu danser en toute liberté.Bon Maxenss est-ce-que l'heure du saké non pasteurisé
À toi de me dire
[MUSIQUE DE TYPE JAPONAISE]
Les amis nous venons d'arriver devant les shops que je veux faire goûter à Maxenss c'est
ceci c'est du saké non
pasteurisé c'est à dire qu'il est non pasteurisé donc peut pas le ramener dans notre pays puisqu'il doit être maintenu au froid c'est du saké
qu'on peut voir que ici au Japon.T'es prêt ?
Ouais
j'suis pas trop pour l'alcool non plus mais je trouve ça vraiment un aspect culturel derrière. Tu m'a-assures
je vais pas vomir
là on boit juste pour gouter et pour découvrir un alcool *Maxence; Tu as vu à quel point je suis pas serein ? *Squeezie; ne t'inquiète pas
C'est pas le
plus mauvais alcool que je vous fais ça avec mon père et mon frère n'avait visité le pavillon d'or est avec toi on va visiter
le pavillon d'argent qui apparemment est mieux que le pavillon d'or en fait maxence vient de reverser la moitié de son verre oui je
crois qu'il est un peu *rire*
ça va eh bien je crois qu'il est un peu pompette
*Lol*
(CHANSON)
Nous sommes au pavillon
d'argent en japonais Ginkakuji tu filmait pas le téléphone ? On voit pas le télépohone ?
ok tout comme un pavillon d'or il y a un endroit où on peut jeter une pièce et faire un vrai voeu. Là faut pas viser dans un petit bocal
comment pavillon d'or il faut viser sur cette pierre juste ici je fais le voeu
je fais le voeu heu :D
Partie ok donc le pavillon d'argent il a été construit par le schéma sens et en fait c'est le grand-père de yoshi massa s'appelait yoshimitsu
qui avait construit le pavillon d'or donc le shogun yoshimasa il l'a fait pour rivaliser avec son grand-père est à la base il devait être
couverts de feuilles d'argent
le fait est qu'il y a eu la guerre et que du coup ça n'a pas abouti ce projet et que du coup c'est le pavillon
de base c'est à dire qu'il n'
y a  ni or ni argent ni architecture typique japonaise traditionnelle
sans feuilles d'or qui recouvre le trucs c'est ça c'est pour ça que japonais on plus tendance à préférer celui-là qui a préféré celui qui est
couvert de feuilles d'or
(Musique)
C'est parti pour dormir.
Demain on va voir natsu!
Ça va être la première fois de ma vie que je rencontre mon futur chien
J'ai trop hate de le voir en vrai d'interagir avec lui en vrai,  en fait.
on se retrouve demain pour le sujet principal de cette vidéo et à demain
Et bien bonjour les amis les j'espère que la nuit était bonne pour vous pour nous elle était très court est d'arriver à fukui fukui
là on attend finalement
la personne de
l'organisme par lequel je passe pour adopter un chien au japon elle va pas tarder à arriver elle serait accompagnée d'une amie à moi
japonaise locale qui l'avait invité au japon même un randonnée en gros je parle anglais avec elle elle traduit en japonais pour l'organisme qui
gère bref il appliqué à temps est-ce qu'on n'a pas trop hâte de voir ces putain il est y compris
les amis on vient d'arriver et il y a une cage en plein milieu avec Natsu dedans c'est fou
mec que j'ai trop envie de sortir !
comment tu va comment tu va
Ses frères et soeurs ont déjà été adoptées par des japonais du coup il est tout seul maintenant
Depuis le temps que je veux te voir je te vois qu'en vidéo !
Il m'a chiqué le nez ça m'a fait mal ! C'est ouf mec j'suis trop heureux il est troooop mignon
Et la suite du programme c'est que (censuré) va le récupérer et
moi en fait je peux pas les ramener en France
avant fin
octobre parce qu'il y a des lois en France bref y'a un vaccin à faire et faut attendre qu'il ait trois mois et moi je pourrais
récupérer fin octobre il sera il connaîtra déjà
des petits tours il sera déjà il sera déjà habitué à la ville surtout aux bruits a voir des enfants, d'autres animaux
Et ça très important pour un chien
on va le ramener dans l'avion là on va prendre l'avion avec lui on va le ramener à tokyo les amis je vous présente Tora
là c'est le père de Natsu il a huit ans et il en pleine mue en fait c'est des chiens qui muent et regardez il est
en train de perdre tous ses poils
[MUSIQUE KAWAI AVEC RENIFLEMENTS]
Les amis je vous présente la maman de Natsu
C'est le moment de le ramener on va prendre l'avion jusqu'à Tokyo
il est sur mes genoux et j'ai un drap parce qu'en fait c'est la première fois de sa vie qu'il prend la voiture
et habituellement un chien quand il prend la voiture pour fois de sa vie il vomit donc il va sûrement vomir ça va aller !
j'ai peur qu'il se mette à crier ou à pleurer le pauvre quitte sa famille là il a dû dire au revoir à son père et à sa maman
triste début d'une nouvelle vie pour toi mon grand et pour moi aussi
Et voilà les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
avec natsu pourquoi ça se termine maintenant parce qu'en fait à partir du moment où j'ai mis les pieds à tokyo avec natsu je n'ai
plus rien filmé voilà j'ai fait que de profiter avec lui pendant les cinq jours où je pouvais le voir alors je peux vous montrer
quelques vidéos prises avec mon téléphone en vertical dégueulasse le premier jour je suis allée me balader avec lui dans le quartier de harajuku
qui était juste à côté de mon hôtel
même si ce détail est inutile alors j'ai été étonné de voir à quel point les japonais sont fans
des shiba
vraiment ils s'arrêtent ils veulent le caresser bon ils te demandent avant bien évidemment je dire en france quand tu balades ton chien
tout le monde s'en bat les couilles
il a fait ses premiers pas dans une ville avec beaucoup de bruit et beaucoup de gens autour mais il a plutôt bien réagi donc
c'est très bon signe et le troisième jour je suis allé à yokohama et là c'est un espace rempli de parcs
il a gambadé dans l'air ça lui a rappelé je pense l'élevage d'où il venait il était
hyper content je l'avais jamais vu autant courir autant se dépenser
bon du coup il a dormi ensuite pendant une heure dans l'herbe mais il était quand même heureux même dans son sommeil c'était la dernière
journée que je pouvais passer avec lui c'était la meilleure de toute je pouvais pas rêver mieux comme dernière journée et puis là-bas j'en suis au
même stade que vous j'attends de pouvoir le revoir tout simplement
merci d'avoir regardé ce petit vlog
j'espère qu'il vous aura plu j'essaie de partager cette rencontre avec vous du mieux que je pouvais même si sur la fin j'étais égoïste en
ne rien filmant j'ai vraiment profité c'est l'important je voulais pas partir en ayant des regrets
voilà n'hésitez pas à passer voir aussi la chaîne de Maxenss qui m'a beaucoup aidé et qui m'a cadré tout simplement pendant ce voyage
à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien et plein d'amour <3